WERE NOT INSINCERE.
GREAT SHOW, GREAT TO SEE TAMMY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT -- EVERY SINGLE
CONSTITUTIONAL, FREEDOM LOVING
AMERICAN, YOU NEED TO WAKE UP.
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK SITUATION.
YOU'VE GOT THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA, THE RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS, THEY HAVE
COLLECTIVELY LOST THEIR MINDS.
THEY DON'T EVEN CARE ABOUT THE
DAMAGE THEY ARE DOING.
IF THEY GET THEIR WAY, THEY WILL
DESTROY EVERYTHING THIS COUNTRY
STANDS FOR.
THE NEW GREENDALE ON TOP OF IT
ALL AND BREAKING TONIGHT WE HAVE
MAJOR NEW INFORMATION THAT THE
CORRUPT MEDIA MOB IS REFUSING TO
SHOW YOU A LOT THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW, IT WILL TAKE THE FULL
HOUR.
NEW PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE OF
SLEEPY, CREEPY, CRAZY UNCLE JOE,
NEW INQUIRIES INTO
HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC, AND
UKRAINE.
WE BROKE THE STORY A WHILE BACK,
YOU HAVE TO THANK THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA MOB.
NEW INFORMATION ALSO TONIGHT
SURROUNDING THE AG'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE RUSSIA WITCH HUNT, THE
OBAMA LEAD COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
ENDEAVORS.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE WILL SHOW YOU
NEW DOCUMENTS UNCOVERED BY
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER JOHN
SOLOMON THAT DESTROYS THE MOBS
ANTI-TRUMP UKRAINIAN FANTASIES.
THIS IS A DEFINING MOMENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS GREAT COUNTRY OF
OURS.
WE ARE NOW AT HISTORIC TIPPING
POINT.
IF YOU ARE UN-AMERICAN AND YOU
CARE ABOUT TRUTH, JUSTICE, RULE
OF LAW, FREE-MARKET ECONOMIC
SYSTEM, THE SANCTITY OF YOUR
BOAT, THE VERY BASIS OF OUR
REPUBLIC, IT'S TIME TO PAY
ATTENTION, GET ENGAGED, PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY FROM THOSE WHO ARE
HELL-BENT ON RESHAPING THIS
COUNTRY WITH MORE LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THE AMERICAN DREAM FOR OUR KIDS
HANGS IN THE BALANCE, THE
DELUSIONAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
LYING MEDIA MOB SPEAKING WITH
ONE VOICE AND A FULL-SCALE
COORDINATED EFFORT TO
DISENFRANCHISE THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THAT ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP.
FOR ANYONE WHO HAS A FUNCTIONING
BRAIN, IT IS NOW MORE CLEAR THAN
EVER.
THE LEFT HAS SUSPENDED ANY
FIDELITY AT ALL TO THE TRUTH, TO
LOGIC, TO REASON, TO BASIC
GOD-GIVEN COMMON SENSE.
IN THEIR WORLD, UP IS DOWN AND
BLACK IS WHITE AND GREEN IS
PURPLE.
EVERYTHING THEY FALSELY ACCUSE
THE PRESIDENT OF DOING, WE WILL
SHOW YOU TONIGHT THEY THEMSELVES
ARE GUILTY OF.
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY 24-HOUR
DAY, WE HAVE WITNESSED NONSTOP
HYSTERIA OVER FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
THEY TOLD US IT WAS IMPORTANT.
IF THE ONLY PROBLEM FOR
DEMOCRATS, IT WAS A LIE, A HOAX,
AND A CONSPIRACY THREE, THREE
LONG YEARS.
IN THE END, THE MUELLER REPORT
WAS A DUD, HIS TESTIMONY WAS AN
EMBARRASSMENT, FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS CLEARED THE WAY.
NOW THE MOB HAS ALTERED THEIR
FAVORITE HOAX AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES FOR A SECOND ROUND OF
BREATHLESS HYSTERIA AND FALSE
REPORTING, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THOSE AROUND
HIM DURING ELECTION CAMPAIGNS
COLLUDED WITH A HOSTILE FOREIGN
POWER.
>> I KEEP GETTING ASKED OTHER
ECHOES OF WATERGATE IN THIS?
THERE ARE.
>> THERE IS ALREADY AMPLE
EVIDENCE IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN ON
THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO SEE IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT USE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO COERCE
THAT LEADER TO MANUFACTURE DIRT
ON HIS OPPONENT AND INTERFERE IN
OUR ELECTION.
>> RUSSIA WAS INTERFERING IN THE
ELECTION AND THEY WEREN'T DOING
IT ON THEIR OWN AND HE WAS IN ON
IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN HAS
GONE AND SOLICITED FOREIGN HELP
FOR HIS ELECTION EFFORT.
>> Sean: BRASWELL RACHEL
MADDOW IS LYING STILL.
ANOTHER CONSPIRACY THEORY --
SAME PEOPLE, SAME HOAX, SAINT
END GOAL, THIS IS ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT THAT ONE REASON FOR THE
MOB AS WELL.
IT'S NOT ABOUT COLLUSION,
NATIONAL SECURITY -- WE WILL
HAVE MORE COMING UP LATER IN THE
SHOW.
FROM THE MOMENT DONALD TRUMP
CAME DOWN THAT ESCALATOR WITH
HIS WIFE, THE LEFT HAS BEEN
HELL-BENT IN TAKING REVENGE AND
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT THAT
YOU ELECTED TO.
WE PUT TOGETHER A COMPREHENSIVE
TIMELINE, IT STARTED JUST TWO
DAYS AFTER DONALD TRUMP SHOCKED
THE WORLD.
WE WERE ONE OF THE FEW THAT TOLD
YOU IT CAN HAPPEN.
>> IF HE TAKES THE RISK OF GOING
TO TRIAL IN    AND HE'S CONVICTE
TO TRIAL IN    AND HE'S CONVICT,
THAT COULD BE IMPEACHABLE.
>> IF HE WERE CAUGHT SNORTING
COCAINE THERE WOULD BE A CHANCE
HE WAS IMPEACHED.
>> IF HE'S NOT A LEGITIMATELY
ELECTED PRESIDENT IN YOUR MIND,
THERE ARE TOOLS THAT CONGRESS
HAS.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW THAT WOULDN'T
BE AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> THAT TWEET FITS THE
REPUBLICAN DEFINITION OF AN
IMPEACHABLE DEFENSE.
>> I WILL FIGHT EVERY DAY UNTIL
HE IS IMPEACHED, IMPEACHED 45!
IMPEACHED 45!
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> IS IMPEACHMENT THE
APPROPRIATE REMEDY?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE IMPEACHMENT.
>> ALL OF THAT MAY BE
IMPEACHABLE.
>> THAT IS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> IS THAT AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE?
OFFENSE TO YOU?
>> HE'S MUCH MORE VULNERABLE TO
IMPEACHMENT.
>> A POTENTIAL INGREDIENT OF
>> WHERE DO YOU SEE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE?
>> IT IS GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMEN
IMPEACHMENT.
>> POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL OR EVEN
IMPEACHABLE.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT, OR
DOES THAT NOT GO FAR ENOUGH IN
YOUR VIEW?
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> THIS TWEET ALONE MAY BE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT IS ON THE TABLE.
>> WHICH IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE?
>> I SAID THEY DON'T BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO GO IN THERE AND WE
ARE GOING TO IMPEACH THE
[BLEEP].
>> DO YOU SEE AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE?
>> IT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> IF THAT'S NOT IMPEACHABLE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHALL BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE ON
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IS IT IMPEACHABLE?
>> 100% IS IMPEACHABLE.
>> VERY SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THE
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> TIPPING POINT, TALK OF
IMPEACHMENT REACHES A FEVER
PITCH ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> Sean: HAT TIP TO OUR
FRIENDS IN MEDIA RESEARCH
HELPING US COMPILE THAT MONTAGE
AND WHEN YOU THINK IT COULDN'T
GET WORSE, CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE
WATERS -- IMPEACHED 45 -- SHE
WANTS THE PRESIDENT LOCKED UP
AND PUT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT -- SO CHARITABLE, NO
DUE PROCESS.
HER FORMER COLLEAGUE BARNEY
FRANK IS ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT
OF BEING A MURDERER, IT KNOWS NO
BOUNDS.
BASIC TRUTH AND JUSTICE HAVE
BEEN TOTALLY ABANDONED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
COLLUDING PARTNERS IN THE MEDIA
MOB.
HERE IS WHAT IS AT STAKE.
LOOK AT THAT MAP, TWEETED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY, THE
VOTES FROM ALL OF THAT READ ON
THAT MAP WILL FOREVER BE
TAINTED.
NO WONDER WHY THEY WANT TO GET
RID OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
STACK THE SUPREME COURT.
RENDERED MEANINGLESS IF THAT MOB
GETS THEIR WAY AND THEIR
LAWLESSNESS GETS THEIR WAY.
IF THIS WAS ABOUT PROTECTING THE
COUNTRY, IF DEMOCRATS CARED
ABOUT COLLUSION AND ELECTION
INTERFERENCE, WHERE WAS THERE
HYSTERIA ABOUT HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON'S DIRTY BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
RECOGNIZES IT WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN A YEAR,
LET THE PEOPLE DECIDE.
I THINK YOU ARE AFRAID OF THAT.
THIS IS HOW AL GREEN SAID WE
BETTER IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE WE
CAN BEAT HIM.
ACCORDING TO A RARE MOMENT OF
TRUTH FROM POLITICO, LOOK AT
THIS -- REAL COLLUSION DID TAKE
PLACE IN 2016, THE MOB DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT IT, DEMOCRATS DON'T
CARE ABOUT IT, IT HAD TO DO WITH
THE DNC, HILLARY CLINTON AND
UKRAINE.
THAT ARTICLE JANUARY 11TH 2017,
LOOK AT THE HEADLINE.
UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO SABOTAGE
TRUMP BACKFIRE, TF OFFICIALS ARE
SCRAMBLING TO AMENDS WITH THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
THEY BET ON THE WRONG HORSE.
IT GOES ON, UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TRIED TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON UNDERMINED TRUMP
BY PUBLICLY QUESTIONING HIS
FITNESS FOR OFFICE.
THEY DISSEMINATED DOCUMENTS
IMPLICATING A TOP TRUMP AID IN
CORRUPTION AND SUGGESTED THEY
WERE INVESTIGATING THE MATTER
ONLY TO BACK AWAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THEY HELPED CLINTON'S ALLIES
RESEARCH DAMAGING INFORMATION ON
TRUMP AND HIS ADVISORS.
EVEN POLITICO ADMITTED IN
JANUARY 2017, THE UKRAINIAN
EFFORTS HAD AN IMPACT IN THE
RACE, HELPING TO FORCE
PAUL MANAFORT'S RESIGNATION,
ADVANCING THE NARRATIVE THAT
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS DEEPLY
CONNECTED TO UKRAINE'S FOE TO
THE EAST, RUSSIA.
BIG NEWS FROM CAPITOL HILL.
LOOK AT THIS FROM
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY,
SENATOR RON JOHNSON RELEASING A
LETTER TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR ASKING HIM TO
INVESTIGATE BRAZEN EFFORTS BY
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE, HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN, TO USE THE GOVERNMENT
OF UKRAINE FOR THE EXPRESS
PURPOSE OF FINDING NEGATIVE
INFORMATION ON THEN CANDIDATE
TRUMP IN ORDER TO UNDERMINE HIS
CAMPAIGN.
NOW YOU HAVE BROUGHT THIS ISSUE
UP.
DIDN'T THE DEMOCRATS SPEND THREE
YEARS CONDEMNING ANY FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE OR COLLUSION WITH
OUR ELECTIONS?
ARE THESE SAME DEMOCRATS AND MOB
MEMBERS WHO ARE BASHING THE
PRESIDENT OVER WHAT IS A
COMPLETELY FABRICATED QUID PRO
QUO?
THERE IS NOTHING IN THAT PHONE
CALL CONVERSATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THE NEW PRESIDENT
IN UKRAINE.
SAME DEMOCRATS, SAY MEDIA LIARS,
AND THE MOB ARE DOING THEIR
BEST, AND RUN FOR COVER BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS FACING TONIGHT
CREDIBLE, SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS
OVER WHAT IS A REAL QUID PRO
QUO.
SEE THE SAME PATTERN?
THEY ACCUSED TRUMP, IT BOUNCES
BACK ON THEM -- THE BOOMERANG.
BIDEN IS RECORDED ON TAPE AND
BRAGGING ABOUT HIM LEVERAGING
YOUR MONEY, A BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH TO GET A UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR FIRED WHO WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON.
WOW.
WATCH THIS.
IF >> WERE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE BILLION DOLLARS, THEY SAID
YOU HAVE NO AUTHORITY, YOU'RE
NOT THE PRESIDENT, I SAID CALL
HIM.
I SAID YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS.
WE LEAVE IN SIX HOURS, IF THE
PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRED, YOU'RE
NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HEG
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HET
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HEF
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HER
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HED
SON OF A [BLEEP], YOU'RE NOT HE.
>> Sean: THE TIMELINE PAINTS A
MUCH DIFFERENT PICTURE, LOOK AT
2014.
BIDEN WAS APPOINTED AS OBAMA'S
POINT PERSON IN UKRAINE.
HIS SON HUNTER SCORED A
LUCRATIVE POSITION ON THE BOARD
OF BURISMA HOLDINGS, THAT'S A
OIL, GAS, ENERGY GIANT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE IN
OIL, GAS, ENERGY, OR THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE.
RECENTLY BIDEN STATED HE NEVER
SPOKE WITH HUNTER ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS BUT A DAMMING
PHOTO OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS
SUGGESTING THAT JOE IS LYING.
AUGUST 2014, THE PHOTO SHOWS
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WITH HIS
SON HUNTER AND HIS SONS SHADY
UKRAINIAN BUSINESS PARTNER NAMED
DEVON ARCHER.
ALSO ON THE BOARD OF BURISMA
HOLDINGS.
JOHN SOLOMON'S REPORTING
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN KNEW THAT
UKRAINE'S TOP PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SONS WORKED
WITH BURISMA AND WAS TIPPED OFF
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THAT'S WHEN BIDEN LEVERAGED A
BILLION DOLLARS IN U.S. AID AND
FORCED THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
TO FIRE A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR,
WOW.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA MOB, NONE
OF THIS IS TRUE.
THIS HAS BEEN DEBUNKED, THIS IS
A CONSPIRACY THEORY COMING FROM
THE BIGGEST CONSPIRACY THEORIST
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> TRUMP IS REFERRING TO
UNFOUNDED ALLEGATIONS THAT AS
VICE PRESIDENT, BIDEN TRIED TO
PROTECT HIS SON BY STOPPING AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE UKRAINIAN
COMPANY THAT HIS SON WORKED FOR.
>> BIDEN AND HIS SON HAVE DENIED
WRONGDOING AND THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE EITHER
HAVE DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
WRONGDOING.
>> HE UNCOVERED NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY WRONGDOING.
>> RUDY GIULIANI CLAIMS WITHOUT
PROOF.
>> UNSUBSTANTIATED.
>> UNFOUNDED ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
BIDEN.
>> HUNTER BIDEN DIDN'T VIOLATE
ANYTHING.
>> Sean: WHY WOULD A
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WANT A PROSECUTOR
TO BE FIRED?
IN TEN DAYS, YOU'RE LYING,
CORRUPT, CONSPIRACY THEORIST AND
THE MOB A DEVOTED SEVEN HOURS,
THE FAVORITE NEW ANTI-TRUMP LINE
CONSPIRACY THEORY, ONLY
46 MINUTES TO BIDEN'S OBVIOUS
QUID PRO QUO.
I WONDER IF THE MEDIA MOB WOULD
COVER THE STORY DIFFERENTLY IF
IT INVOLVED DON JR. AND THE
TRUMP FAMILY OR EVEN BARREN
TRUMP FOR CRYING OUT LOUD?
WE WILL GET YOU THE FULL
TIMELINE, INCLUDING BRAND-NEW
ALLEGATIONS TONIGHT FROM CHINA.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE, THIS
STORY WILL BE DEVASTATING, A
HUGE BOOMERANG TO THE MOB, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND THIS IS
THE END FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE DNC CAN NOW BE FULLY
INVESTIGATED FOR REAL COLLUSION,
THEY ARE DOING US A FAVOR, THEY
ARE DOING DONALD TRUMP THE
BIGGEST FAVOR AND THE PRESIDENT
WILL NOT BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE,
HIS CALL WITH THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT, THERE WAS NOTHING
WRONG WITH IT -- ZERO.
NO MISCONDUCT, NO QUID PRO QUO.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT TO YOURSELF.
THE ONLY FAVOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
REQUESTED FROM HIS UKRAINIAN
COUNTERPART DURING THE CALL WAS
AN INQUIRY INTO THE ELECTION
HACKING FROM 2016 INVOLVING
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC IN
UKRAINE.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES HAS A SWORN
DUTY, A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
INVESTIGATE CRIMES.
UNITED STATES HAS A TREATY WITH
UKRAINE, SEVERAL OTHER COUNTRIES
LIKE AUSTRALIA, ITALY,
GREAT BRITAIN -- IT REQUIRES
COOPERATION IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THAT'S NOT
ALL.
LOOK AT YOUR CONSTITUTION,
ARTICLE TWO, SECTION THREE, IT
STATES THE PRESIDENT SHALL TAKE
CARE THE LAWS BE FAITHFULLY
EXECUTED.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T CARE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T BLUDGEON TRUMP WITH
IT.
THE PRESIDENT'S SWORN
RESPONSIBILITY, IT IS HIS
CONSTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO UPHOLD
THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS TRAVELED
MULTIPLE TIMES TO MULTIPLE
COUNTRIES TO DETERMINE IF
AMERICA'S INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES WERE ILLEGALLY USED
AGAINST AMERICA'S CITIZENS.
THIS PROBE IS REPORTEDLY RAMPING
UP SOON.
WE WILL KNOW IF THE MOST
SENSITIVE WEAPONS OF
INTELLIGENCE WERE TURNED AGAINST
AMERICANS AND A SITTING
PRESIDENT AND A CANDIDATE.
WE WILL KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THESE
TOP INTEL PEOPLE WERE
CIRCUMVENTING U.S. LAWS AND
SPYING ON THEIR OWN CITIZENS,
OUTSOURCING WHAT IS OTHERWISE
ILLEGAL, THAT WOULD BE
SURVEILLANCE OF AMERICANS TO
INTEL AGENCIES AND ALLIED
COUNTRIES.
LIKE I SAID, BRITAIN, ITALY,
AUSTRALIA.
WE WILL HAVE SO MUCH MORE ABOUT
THE UNELECTED DEEP STATE
BUREAUCRATS IN EVERY AGENCY AND
OUR GOVERNMENT.
ONLY A FEW BUT THEY ARE DOING
DAMAGE TO OUR COUNTRY, ACTIVELY
WORKING AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
THEY'VE UNITED STATES, HE CAN'T
EVEN BE THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS CARL BERNSTEIN NOW KNOWS,
EVEN HIS SOURCES ARE SAYING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS GOING TO TRY
TO DELIVER REAL EVIDENCE, THAT
IN FACT THIS HAS BEEN A
DEEP STATE CONSPIRACY LIKE THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ALLEGING.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT THE PRESIDENT,
REPUBLICANS, OR DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE SAFETY,
SECURITY, AND SANCTITY OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE.